meantime teenage protestor who was shot
in the chest by Hong Kong police has
been charged with rioting and assaulting
an officer the 18 year old student shot
at close range during a demonstration in
protest of the 70th anniversary of
communist rule in China on Tuesday
straight to Hong Kong Hong Kong our
special correspondent i'ts Crawford is
there have image slightly breaking up
there Alex but I think we can still see
you yes we can
masks on so I'm guessing teargas
problems yes they have put tear gas Mart
on themselves right I'm being tried to
get on the pavement they're very very
twitching actually British policeman
who's been coordinating the whole thing
anyway I got word they have been having
a lot of trouble from the crowds you can
see there's lots of them all the way
along the pavements every street
they're getting a lot of thing called
murderers killers
now they've been securing because
restoring liveth you can see they're
egging them on and they they use these
bright neon laser lights to shine on
them to turn dazzle them because they
are shining torches in citizens faces if
you have a look down here you can see
how many please don't have to turn up
and they're constantly being bombarded
with this platform by people who are
just come down from their flats just
come down from this won't take you a
little bit further along here to get
offensive shouting calling really taking
the home with the police having to
control them
[Applause]
and I think the shooting of the
teenagers they have been faced with a
big law and order problem its mountain
there's been lots of reports circulating
that the Hong Kong authorities are
considering a police request to
introduce or give them
they want they want them to introduce
[Applause]
these clear
they are killing us
destroying these infrastructure young
advanced nations are being accused of
being complicit with the blues by
shutting down networks where the
protesters are trying to move around
that's how they keep on targeting the
underground station
we saw there attacking China businesses
Chinese banks so they try to control
this land Elizabeth US law and order
problem that they all clearly very very
tense themselves they react very badly
to the cat porn like shouting back at
them and in some places re sort of hours
earlier going in and try to make slapped
arrest for people who are calling them
names so it's a it's very very difficult
at a very very tense situation at home